bonjour vous allez voir une vidéo bonus
que j'ai réalisé avec norman pour la
soirée des 10 ans de la fondation
culture et diversité qui aide les jeunes
des milieux défavorisés à accéder aux
arts et à la culture alors pendant cette
soirée on est monté sur scène avec
norman pour présenter cette vidéo parle
des musées forcément sur la culture
et puis on s'est dit que ce serait
dommage de pas vous la montrer à vous
les internautes du coup c'est ce que
vous allez voir
bon visionnage moi souvent quand je vais
au musée mecs vont au musée quoi le truc
de riches ou paie mon ticket pour voir
des heures alors là non la plupart des
musées ont des horaires de gratuité voir
sont totalement gratuits le louvre par
exemple est gratuit pour les moins de 26
ans
ça ne coûte rien n'y a pas moins cher
que rien bienvenue au musée ça vous
coûtera un homme allongé pas rien soir
maintenant la sape est possible il faut
qu'on paye pas les gens tout ça ça coûte
rien d'altruiste moi je m'incruste mois
mais il n'y a pas un musée avec des
thèmes très variés moi par exemple
j'adore la bande dessinée et il ya des
très grands musées qui ont exposé des
oeuvres 2 à oui parce que c'est vrai que
dans les musées il ya aussi des gardiens
qui ont dû repartir mais souvent dans
les musées les gardiens demanda à garder
le silence
autant dans une bibliothèque je
comprends est en train de travailler 2
il faut pas déranger les gens mais dans
un musée ça dérange qui l'étoile c'est
super vieux ce à quoi aux 3000 ans et ma
femme néfertiti quai dans son tombeau
qui essaient de dormir
donc ok il existe différents types de
musée pour un petit peu tous les goûts
art moderne art contemporain histoire
naturelle et même des musées spécifiques
le musée du chocolat par exemple je suis
pas allé paraît que c'est très bien
c'est un exposé du chocolat quoi c est
ce que tu sens l'impérialisme italien
il perd pas d'assez transfigure le super
kg du sens
bref âge 220 ça et le chocolat ouais
donc au chocolat ouais vous déranger le
super kilos là
ayant pas quelqu'un là-bas c'est un le
musée du chocolat ça a l'air très bien
et aussi les musées d'art moderne
si vous allez dans ce genre de musée
vous pouvez tomber sur des performances
et des gens qui font des performances
ici vous avez jamais vu ça c'est assez
surprenant
c'est une oeuvre d'art à prendre
non tu vas dans un musée et que tu vois
une oeuvre que tu connaissais sur la
joconde ans et compte pas mais tu es un
petit peu fier quand même tu fais
retiens ça je connais tout ça c'est un
artiste américain c'est du cubisme s'est
il s'appelle
alors ça c'est une certaine secours
c'est une sortie de squeez toujours
parqués dans les musées d'art moderne
une grande partie des oeuvres n'avait
pas de nom voilà qui s'appelle sans bon
sens titres en anglais mais les mecs
s'en fout ouais mon oeuvre est là pas de
nom parce que je suis contre les
étiquettes les formalités voilà ça
s'exprime à travers la spontanéité ça
n'a pas de bon par contre elle a bien
appris à un prix je les choisis oui tout
à fait je prends la carte bleue
d'ailleurs plus les chèques désole dans
les musées il ya un type de personne
c'est les appels et dessinateur c'est
souvent des étudiants en école d'art
comme ça qu'ils dessinent dans les
musées quoi il je pense qu'ils essayent
de faire un petit peu mieux que j'aurais
fait ça plus tôt
il
à chaque fois je vais dans un musée
d'histoire naturelle que je vois les
ossements anciens la de nos ancêtres et
où je me dis mais mais peut-être qu'on
peut terminer nous aussi dans un musée
toi moi je sais pas alors ici vous avez
les youtuber et puis on peut marquer
l'histoire
ah bon même pas du tout on peut le dire
d'ailleurs on va les branches et je
pense que c'est encore mieux abat
d'abord on a le dab bank est
complètement disparu j'ai tard un petit
mouvement du 21e siècle
je vous dis à très vite pensé à moi la
prochaine fois que vous irez dans un
musée que vous verrez c'est ma chaise je
peux parler fort si je veux ce mais ce
n'est pas une performance artistique
vous avez vraiment finir par payer
néfertiti